[Music]
I hate intros mob psycho 100 episode 1
what better way to start off an anime
than with the random fight scene now we
get an introduction of breaking out
Ataka
who is discussing business with Hanako
she's asking him to exorcise the spirit
and while he seems confident he'll be
able to do so hanukkah's boyfriend is
suspicious that he is a fake
and of course assuming you've seen the
show you know that he is indeed a fake
so when they encountered the evil spirit
he proves to be useless forcing him to
call in our hero and real psychic
hugging a mushy gay or ma mobs OPD deals
with the spirit and cocky mod-2 mobs
younger brother is introduced and of
course what's an anime without a love
interest in this case its tsuba me who
was surrounded by friends with an
emphasize a relevancy my better they can
get a job to exorcise a haunted tunnel
where people have gone missing mob deals
with the spirits and their boss who were
a biker gang that died to a banana code
for bonus points he also exercises in
ancient spirit who's forcing them to
haunt the tunnel freeing them to pass on
episode 2 mana scripts by porn sites
that I can use as erotic massages to
exorcise said I realizes he wants to do
something more with his youth but he's
not entirely sure what introducing
co-directed Tomi and the telepathy Club
who will be shut down by the student
council if they don't find a new member
in two days full panic mode and Suzan
after not being able to find anyone they
ask mob to join their club and after
being discouraged by it again he's not
entirely sure so he doesn't even answer
hi gonna mob being sexually confused
while infiltrating an all-girls school a
bench of peer supporter gets into a
heated argument with Regan
forcing mom to go alone alleged lesbians
threaten mob other alleged lesbians
explained that the school's haunted mob
understand the Intel spirit haunting the
girls school
allegedly
before being exorcised the spirit asked
mom if he's living to the fullest making
think about what he really wants he
comes to the conclusion that he wants to
be with Subhan me so he joins the body
improvement Club you become more
appealing that's the body improvement
Club gets the room instead of the
telepathy Club episode three mob is
working hardening the body improvement
club mob flexes his powers to the
telepathy Club and in her spots go doubt
they explains her dreams mob is lured
into a new religious order by a masked
woman with the temptation of becoming
popular nickimja the religion is built
around dimpled their leader being able
to make everyone laugh when he arrives
at the gathering people force him on
stage with other newcomers where he runs
into Masato Ichi a girl from his class
who is reporting on the suspicious group
the newcomers are forced into masks and
quickly start laughing like the rest mop
unaffected by the mask realizes the
gathering isn't about being popular so
he decides to leave shocked that he
isn't laughing dimple challenges him to
a staring contest with a mouthful of
milk where you can't laugh mob accepts
naturally because he likes milk
he beats followers sells him for a
simple mob wins most revealing everyone
is under hypnosis by dimple who is an
evil spirit dimple while taunting mob
causes the first explosion loses the
fight gets transformed into a small
spirit and that balls mob around fight
oh oh hey yeah yes I know
episode 4 middle-school beings have a
fight where Oni gabato tango or tango
the demon is introduced then immediately
loses to hanazawa tokue key which cues
his introduction and back over to mob
who's contemplating exercising Diplo but
his convinced to let him stay since he
promised not to do anything bad but
dimple is actually planning on
possessing mop and just waiting for his
chance
Regan uses Photoshop to erase the spirit
from the picture we then get a glimpse
of a growing jealousy from Manitou
towards his brother
tango being defeated by Ted who seeks
help from the body improvement Club to
win against black vinegar middle school
after being refused they plot to get mob
kidnapped by the black vinegar gang so
the club is forced to fight and get him
back they bribe mops they get head into
getting him captured dimple tries to
convince mob to use his powers to get
free but mob refuses because he doesn't
use them on people hearing that mob was
taken the body Improvement Club agrees
to fight to get him back they retrieved
mob and make quick work of the gang
however there's still no match for Ted
oh who is actually using psychic powers
to win the fight
mop season reveals to tattoo that he too
has powers while urging him not to use
them on people episode 5 teddy was
surprised by mob having cards but
immediately wants to fight him to prove
he is stronger so he taxed but mob
easily defense Dipple was trying to
convince mob to fight back by mob
refuses with mom not fighting back Ted
who throws him around since he still
refuses to fight back dimple steps in to
try and defend him because he still
wants to possess his body but Ted who
exercises him with no problem with no
reaction for Mom Teddy who attacks with
everything he's got the fight ends up in
a home Ekrem where Ted who shoots knives
hit mob while defending mob accidentally
cuts off Teddy's hair Ted who's a pretty
boy drama coin so naturally goes into a
show your teeth or would seem yourself
book enough to go through the chaos mob
explains that Teddy was just scared of
finding that he has nothing without his
powers just another average person with
his ego being threatened Theriault ex
mob with his bare hands choking him
against a wall even under the threat of
death mob still refuses to use his
powers and instead throws him in saint
haymakers shockingly the punches aren't
enough and mob thinks back on when him
and his brother or attacked he blacked
out and used his powers on the high
school attackers hurting them as well as
his brother in the process he promised
himself that that would happen again and
he stays true to that promise but in
turn falls unconscious
[Music]
while unconscious he falls into some
sort of transcended state with even more
power than before and attacks Ted who
ending the fight with one blow making
that who realize just how average he is
book bullying see dr. mob second
explosion occurs when he is overwhelmed
with sadness and the thought of not
being able to conquer himself which
conveniently fixes this school the last
scene is Bob's brother recalling the
high school attackers and thinking that
whatever attacked them wasn't his
brother episode six so they can perform
seance
tell me wants to find out their psychic
psych mod 32 overhears tanga apologizing
them up but misunderstands that thinks
mob is being bullied as a part of the
student council e2 urges them to take
action against the school's delinquents
Camuto Shinji the student council
president likes the idea and agrees on
his way home buddy sues mistaken for his
brother and approached by meat soda
Kenji with an offer to join an awakening
lab to improve psychic abilities mob and
toe may look for other psychics while
looking mob senses an adult psychic but
he feels dangerous so it doesn't say
anything relates who wanted to be like
his brother goes to the lab and meets
other psychics the next day Camuto calls
nearly two and plots to Frank tanga and
the delinquents Lydia's hesitant to the
idea first but eventually agrees and
it's pretty unfortunate timing because
tanga is turning over a new leaf
once he's framed tanga tries convincing
the class of his innocence but being a
delinquent nobody really believes him
but he Sue's guilt is eating away at him
and while at the lab he shows his first
sign of powers but leaves before
noticing it without realizing his power
yet he heads home and sees dimple
waiting for mob but isn't sure what he
is Episode seven mops reputation has
spread to all the gangs who now refer to
him as white tea poison all the gang
leaders want to defeat White's he
poisoned for the reputation
[Music]
yes hearing authority to end up teaming
up in an attempt to surpass mob
meanwhile Camarillo is drunk with power
and start spending more and more people
using hue to to help them ladies whose
powers filled by his guilt so the more
he friends people the stronger yet sorry
yeah sorry about Pokemon Scannell about
did he do anything word gets around
about it he to framing everybody so a
group of guys confront him but he uses
his powers to fight against them taro
who just so happy to be walking by
notices elites are using his powers
against all these guys so he decides to
put him in his place
Connor his target my by having him break
a base now supposedly there's a spirit
he was after him but you two fights a
gang leader who was looking for whites
he poison eventually all the gang
leaders come looking for a t2 in
response to this and he is forced to
fight them all at once while the adult
side kick that mob had noticed earlier
is watching from a rooftop the last
scene is mob coming across 32 with all
the gang leaders injured around him Lisa
nany octenol episode 8 are you to
explains that the only reason he was
ever nice to mob was because he feared
him but now that he had powers he wanted
to fight mop dimple who of course knows
how Opie mob is once no part of this and
knope's right the hell out of there
mob doesn't believe this and dismisses
that as a lie
of course mob isn't going to fight his
brother so it's tight he apologizes to
the gang members for his brother hurting
them the adult psychic or mega Mook
Aoyama who is still watching is ordered
to take in hurt soo so he attacks him
and this makes mobs explosion timer
skyrocket
or dotto
our first mob doesn't fare so well
against him but once the explosion timer
props even mega moves no matter of God
in desperation Mega mu used as a
powerful date-rape drug which he keeps
handy for feisty females rendering mob
incapacitated Megumi then takes off with
32 dimple went to find taro who helps
mob get back to his house and explains
more about the situation the people who
took his brother are part of an
organization called claw with over a
hundred psychics they aim to start a
revolution after hearing more about this
Dibble takes him to the awakening lab
which had been attacked they run into
meat soda Kenji who tells him about the
attack and how the psyche cell were
there were kidnapped and in the last
scene the psychics athletes who are
going to some isolated facility we kick
off episode 9 with my goomah discussing
what happened with mob went added
another member of the claw overhears him
Terra does threatened by mob because he
is afraid of mob joins the claw he will
be surpassed by him so he sets out on a
private mission to kill mob Ted who
tells mob that he will help get his
brother back but they have no
information go on that is until Terra de
arrives to fight mob if they sue loses
and is tortured into giving all the
information he has on claw including the
location of the facility where Dee's
who's being held we get a quick
introduction of the claws 7th division
upper echelon members as well as the
leader meanwhile elite soon the site
characters are being held in a Cell
which doesn't last long because they use
their powers to get free data deletes
mob and teddy to the facility attacks
them and gets one shot by mob mega boom
gets his rematch which unfortunately
isn't very close
so with manga move neutralized clot is
now forced to use all of its members of
the seventh division to try and stop mob
okay episode 10 clot release its upper
echelon members known as scar as well as
all their grunts to hunt down mob and
everyone else because who finds the
shaded Rd brother who was separated from
them dimple who was possessing a body
gets into a fight with scar member mato
who controls the evil spirits to fight
for him Ted who gets into a fight with
scar member miyagawa who has pyrokinetic
powers but after managing to win that
fight teddy was knocked unconscious and
held captive while this is happening mob
is targeted by scar member Mukai leads
who gives everyone else a chance to
escape while fighting off not scar
members show after beating Mook eyes
puppets mob is forced to fight sky
remember soo chia and Takeuchi neither
amounting to much of a challenge for
Nani map finally finally - who is badly
hurt and approaches explosion with mob
not paying attention Muto sees an
opportunity to attack him with illusions
while being attacked mobs explosion
procs reflecting the illusion back on a
Muto rendering them both unconscious
ma petite ooh tattoo and diplo are all
captured and held by the scars dimple
who is defeated by mat-su is forced into
a poisoned jar with hundreds of spirits
who devour each other and get stronger
creating a new pet for Matsuya episode
11 lincoln tracks mobs flown out to the
facility which could be considered weird
but i think his intentions are good and
if not I ship it
once mob is of age my abilities are
finally reunited by held with taro in a
room that cancels out their power Regan
is mistaken as the boss of the claw
organization allowing him to unknowingly
help the captured psyches escape as well
as getting them up as everyone is
preparing to leave they run into issue
guru the 7th division leader you should
due to a threatens I'm sorry and
dropkicks him to avoid mob using his
powers and as it turns out things
escalate pretty fast after that and
everyone is forced to fight
mob comes close to exploding during the
fight because he feels the need to
protect everyone but I get slapped him
back to reality we get a look at how do
I get him I'll come to know each other
which is shortly before they can is cut
down from behind raising mobs explosion
timer to a hundred percent and finally
episode 12 it turns out Aegon isn't
actually hurt in fact he's powerful way
more powerful than the scars they each
take turns attacking him but none of
them can even come close to his power
how can you call me now
what happened was when mob was about to
explode leg and snapped him out of it
and all that built up energy changed his
direction of foot into legging putting
him at a thousand percent power they can
makes the most of this opportunity to
give a good tongue lashing to all the
scar members and not the fun sexual kind
the hurtful kind and not the fun sexual
hurtful kind he explains that they're
all just average people despite their
powers you should go to hook disagrees
and prepares to attack again
that's one show the supposed attempt
steps in and quickly defeats him show is
actually from HQ and was scouting for
talent division 7 but ends up dissolving
in said dimple when the ghost battle
royale and is released everyone leaves
and everything starts going back to
normal mob is still creepin on tsubomi
and is flustered by eye contact Komodo
realizes the error of his ways
tango forgives both Goomba and Lisa for
framing him and is now part of the body
improvement Club taro becomes a teacher
for the awakening lab helping the side
characters dimple continues to help mob
leave - and mobs relationship starts
going back to the way it was and finally
we get the Segway scene with show who is
actually the son of the claws boss
reporting to his dad and receiving the
news that the boss will be in Japan soon
she call you know leg it makes the most
of this opportunity to give a good map
him out of it and all day
turns out legging is actually her its
tactical but not everyone can you commit
that's one to suppose opting out of it
and build them that's what showed the
supposed attempt
I built up energy changed her it both
kudo and Ritu and for frame close to
spar what happened to us when mob was
about to be slow slow to attacking it
that's what sho mob is still creepin on
sue Bomi isn't leg and snapped in
[Music]
skating for - oh God dimple one the
ghost by Tara
yes hold up energy change this direction
in Florida
tango forgives both directions foot into
legging making and finally episode 12 it
turns out again hasn't actually hurt in
fact he's powerful way more powerful
than the scars they each take turns
attacking them but none of them can even
come close to his power what happened
was when mob was about to explode leg
and snapped him out of it and all that
built up energy changed his direction of
fluid into legging putting him at a
thousand percent power they can make the
most of this opportunity to give a good
tongue lashing to all the scar members
and not the fun sexual kind the hurtful
kind and not the fun sexual hurtful kind
of explains that they're all just
average people despite their powers you
should go to a disagrees and prepares to
attack again
that's one show the supposed attempt
steps in and quickly defeats him show is
actually from HQ and was scouting for
talent and division 7 but ends up
dissolving in set temple when the ghost
battle royale and is released everyone
leaves and everything starts going back
to normal
mob is still creepin on sue Bomi and is
flustered by eye contact
Komodo realizes the error of his ways
tango forgives both Cumbre and Lisa for
framing him and is now part of the body
improvement Club taro becomes a teacher
for the awakening lab helping the side
characters dimple continues to help mob
lead to a mobs relationship starts going
back to the way it was and finally we
get the Segway scene with show who is
actually the
son of the claws boss reporting to his
dad and receiving the news that the boss
will be in Japan soon